I read all the comments on YouTube on  Tick Tock I read them all I read the  cynicism and the what about the gas and  what about this  and then I look right here  look at this  there are people out there actually  doing it right actually going putting in  the effort and changing their families  lives and honestly with the recession  gaining more and more momentum I'm  incredibly concerned how this winter  plays out going into 23. a lot of people  watching this right now could really use  not only the side cash maybe not at this  level  thousand dollars a month extra  the side cash but also the learnings the  learnings that had a thumbnail on  postmark were on eBay or on Amazon the  copy you have to write the skills of  marketing and selling even twice please  take these headlines seriously